ce soir, il y a des gens qui
pensaient-ils aller voir ursrsrs
brailler, mais je souris. On esn
celui qui connaît la plus forte
croissance. Quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas vu au Qu d d dans
l'histoire politique récente.
Les trois autres partis
d'opposition ont décliné, on est
le seul qucococonnu une
croissanacacacacacacacacacacacas
conservateurs qui ont mis le X
à la bonne place.
Au moment où je vous parle, on a
trexexexactement le même nombreu
Québec, mais il manque 20
pupuputés.On est d'une certainen
prise avec une distorsion
démocratique du siècle, comme
disait le devoir la semaine
dernière. Il va falloir qu'on en
parle un peu plus tard.
C'est évident qu'il ne faut pas
être trop pessimiste ce soir.
Quand Québec solidaire a
commencé à sa première élection,
ils ont fait moins de 4 %
et tout le monde disait comment
c'était extraordinaire. Quand
avec Mario Dumont, c'était 6,5 %
du vote. Aujourd'hui c'est 13 %
et ça va continuer à mon
Je suis très content de nous.
(applaudissements)
c'était une bataille de David
contre Goliath. Vofrfrfrfrfrfrfn
des ressources de nos
adversaires.
Au début, quand j'ai annoncé moa
direction arararti, c'était un
parti qu 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 e
vote. Regardez tout le chemin
qu'o
(audududissements)la première éa
des candidats qui arrivent. Vous
avaient tous fait une campagne
extraordinaire.
sport national, il y a trois
périodes. La première période se
C'était de s'assurer de devenir
un grand parti, de faire parti
de la cour des grands.
Et on l'a accompli de façon
magistrale.
(applaudissements)
mieux passait que ce que je
pensais qui allais arriver.
Je ne pensais pas qu'on allait
participer au débat des chefs,
qu'on allait être de toutttttttt
être invité à tous les grands on
finirait pratiquement sur un
pied d'égalité lestrtrtre
parties de position. Ce qui rend
le plus fier, notre plus grand'r
permis de débattre des idées qui
se sont revévévées au centre de
la campagne électorale. Si le
parti conservateur n'avait pas
été là
question du secteur privé en
santé. On aurait pas parlé de la
libe
éducation et dans les services
de garde. Il n'aurait pas été
question de relancer le projet
GNL au Sagnay.
d'exploitation responsable de
nos hydrocarbures sur le
territoire québécois.
On aurait pas parlé des
cachotteries de François Legault
sur le troisième lien et on aura
pas parlé de l'inutile tramway à
Québec. Il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on a vues et qu'on a
réussi à mettre au coeur des
engagements politiques au
présence du parti conservateur
dans tous les débats.
Je vous en remercie du fond du
débat d'idées au Québec. Bravo.
(applaudissements)
je veux vous remer l l les
militants conserlelelelelelelels
motivés et les plus souriants,
les plus dynlelelelelelelelelels
avaient permis
rassemblem d d de plus de 1000
personnes.
arrivé
au total plus de 12 000
pers
êtes vraiment
extraordinaires.
(applaudissements)
et de vos sourires. Vos poignées
de main me donnent des sourires.
Merci du fond du coeur. Je veux
période parce qu'il y aura une
va devoir avoir lu. Ça va
commencer demain matin. D'ici la
on a des assises importantes. On
a fini deuxième dans plusieurs
On a des organisations
maintenant dans toutes les
circonscriptions. On va avoir du
financement public à la même
hauteur que les autres par
d'opposition.
(applaudissements)
on a semé de l'espoir depuis
plusieurs mois dan c c coeur et
dans la tête de bien des
Québécois. Cvavava être le temps
de commencer à consolider tout
ça. On va avoir plus de temps
pour mieux o
On était dans une courte période
de temps, arararti qui n'avait
pas de rmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpme
ressources. J'ai confiance que
la deuxième période, on va se
ba
va permettre à David de
ututut en s'assurant qu'on va
fragiliser les pieds du Goliathe
fragiliser devant nous.
(applaudissements)
évidemment, la troisième
période, vous la connaissez
tous, ça va être la prochaine
campagne électorale. Je l'ai dit
dès le début, depuis le 22
novembre 2020 quand j'ai annoncé
mon intention de briguer la
direction du parti conservateur,
je serai encore là à l
(applaudissements)
on va frapper à plus de porte.
On va semer encolululus
d'espoir.
(cris de la
merci.
- On t'aime!eu beaucoup de plaià
votre rencontre depuis deux ans.
Je n'en serais jamais trop
reconnaissant. On est parti avec
une claque et une bottine et on
a fait ce que personne n'avait
fait. C'est grâce à chacun de
vous. Je vais avoir besoin de
vous encore plus au cours des
quatre prochaines années pour
agrandir ce mouvement.
félicitant nos adversairescecece
que les Québécois ont choisi de
continuer. Nous, on a choisi de
continuer à les avoirleleleursea
aller dans cette direction. Je
veux féliciter mon adversaire
ici Sylvain Lévesque.
Je veux féliciter François
Legault eseses autres 123
députés qui ont été élus c